Caesar calls on daddy and Koko to assist
in the rehabilitation of the Wilsons
dogs right right that right there's that
right hey so you know earlier you say I
think he might recognize them
Judy kita you didn't he went after him
right he went he did but not as much as
not exactly usually what I do when a
neighbor and his golden retriever joined
the group Maui's aggression instantly
escalates into the redzone absolutely
aggression he was definitely his
intention was just to deliver a bike why
not show this is what this is this is
what I'm telling you how ain't a-gonna
Retriever behaving absolutely calm
submissive good example at that time I
was not able to create the behavior that
I want from them from the beginning you
know so I came up with a different
approach
grab the dog bring it closer to the
target to his target mouth which target
and let him face the other way so just
to the sense of tie the situation but I
didn't feel that I make them surrender
so sometimes touching them you know the
way I was that will not change the
behavior so you gotta come out with a
different approach
I told Jeannie and Dave to stay back and
I took the kids you bring her and the
parents are staying in the back there
okay okay to be a role model and she
okay kids this is how we supposed to
walk this how he's supposed to deal with
people this is you know this is what
that dog is saying to our dogs is how
we're gonna deal with the situation just
don't let her be in front of it there
you go
which is gonna pass by and our team have
to learn just to pass by they've never
walked hula not even one time because he
would never go with them and I had the
same thing I tried to protect him and so
I walked him so that was just wonderful
for me to see it's easier to teach
children and to teach adults you know
hey because they don't have this bad
habit so ingrained and them I just need
to make sure that I'm projecting calm
assertive energy so let's go back to the
golden retriever because we didn't win
there then at that time I said you know
what I don't feel that I accomplished
what I what I normally accomplish with a
dog that I work with so I want to go
back and see the bone retriever and show
the bone retriever
look guy we're different today
Hey
that's this is I need this state of mind
remember earlier I was not able to
convince them from here
to stop going after him he is a role
model of them so this way he's teaching
a different way of greeting this
beautiful golden retriever see so the
the insecure dog that we have in the
family is acting much better than the
other dogs who are Dom in a state you
can always go back and redo the scenario
what a good look if you go over to
dreaming you everybody